folks
if you enjoyed like this entire time i'm
sitting there watching her and i have a
conversation and i'm enjoying that
conversation that was my favorite part
too
but by the way you know
poised you know respectful all of that i
mean you know jeddah that has gone
against hillary clinton so when are you
going against heavyweights anybody else
i was very impressed by her i'm not
saying that we agreed or disagreed on
every but nikki as far as a person and
carrying herself
i think she's pretty i enjoyed the
debate hi caliber this was grandfather
we're going to do many many more of
these so folks stick around but we got
to make announcements yes or no yeah we
got no i'm going to let you do it yeah
so let me
let me tell you what happened so i think
some of the audience knows some of you
don't know some of you guys that are
members here that are signing up to
become members uh uh uh you know i'm
excited for you because you'll see why
there's gonna be other benefits of being
members if you haven't yet may want to
consider being a member so
first time jedidiah was on a podcast how
many months ago was that was that like
six
seven months ago about six or so yeah
was it that long no it was not because
it was in this and this
five months ago let's say four months
ago okay four or five months ago so we
sat down we spoke right afterwards i'm
like man i love this the way she talks i
love the world you know energy would you
admit was it the three of us yes okay
would you admit what you said to me
you're like i gotta go but go recruit
her would you
i was like hey
which is exactly that's exactly what
happened what are you up to after this
100 percent
good to know that we're making things
happen so
yeah that's right so then we have
conversations and one thing led to
another and then multiple conversation
with jeremy and then i said what would
this look like and then you were kind of
sharing this and anyways we're here to
announce to everybody that's watching
this that jedediah has officially joined
the valuetainment team and i got to tell
you we're ecstatic that's an
understatement to see how ecstatic we
are to have yourself jeremy hartley now
being down here in florida and getting
more of you and in valuetainment the
audience loved you when he had john so
matter of fact are you okay if we show
the video let's show the promo do it
let's see go ahead play the promo video
[Music]
i'm jetta diabeela
i've hosted and co-hosted cable news
shows network tv shows all of it
i hated the filters and there were many
i struggled with the time constraints
that stifled conversation i sometimes
felt like i was drowning in producer
direction
what i wanted was to get to the heart of
big issues to be real and to have an
honest conversation with people who
agreed with me and disagreed with me
people who would make us think and help
fix what's broken
i couldn't do what i wanted to do what i
needed to do in the spaces i was in
so i was ready to find a new space
i believe so strongly in individual
freedom i love this country but it's a
mess right now and i'm not going to
sugarcoat that with fake giggles and
rainbows i want to talk about why things
are so [ __ ] up not just in politics
but everywhere health fitness dating
culture it all needs a good hard look
welcome to my new zone this is jetta
diablo live on valuetainment
i'm excited about that jedidiah i know
i'm so excited when you watch that promo
video you're just like you kind of like
want to work out you want to do
something i got to give a shout out to
the editing team
and let me tell you we had such a fun
day shooting that it was amazing um it's
it's a great team here all around um and
was that a real workout you were doing
all the views
i work out like crazy um and we're gonna
do some fun stuff on the show related to
that we're gonna we're gonna have some
amazing guests um going to be a lot of
me ranting it's going to be everything's
on the table so it's not just politics
people know me from politics i'm big
into health and wellness fitness
pop culture dating we're going to cover
it all we're going to be real and we're
going to dig you know i really want to
like do some deep dives i want to have a
real conversation um and if we have a
guest it's going to be someone that i
really want to talk to my goal here
is to make people feel powerful over
their own lives again i feel like
there's a lot of sentiments out there of
negativity people feel powerless they
feel like they're kind of like shrinking
in their seats it's been a tough two
years i want to remind people that a lot
is possible and it's right within their
reach so it's going to be it's going to
be fun so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]